Let's solve a few more systems of equations using
but we will not use them
elimination in one step.
We will need to convert some equations,
to prepare them for elimination.
Let's say we have the equation 5x - 10y = 15
And we have another equation 3x - 2y = 3.
We want to solve the system using elimination.
We could use substitution, we could present graphically
the two equations and find where the intersections are crossing.
But we will use elimination.
The first thing you might say is, "Hey, Sal, we know that
in the elimination method we remove the left side
one equation from the other or we collect them and then
we collect the two right sides. "
I can do this because, basically, this is adding
of the same thing to both sides of the equation.
But here is not obvious that
this will be beneficial.
If we collect these two left-hand sides, we would get it
8x - 12y.
This will not remove any one variable.
And on the right side
we will stay with one number.
And if we get out, it will not
remove any one variable.
How will elimination help us here?
And the answer is that we can multiply the two equations
in such a way that one of these is possible
members can be canceled with one of the others.
And indeed, you can choose which member
you want to remove.
Let's say we want to remove y members.
So I will just write this 5x - 10y here again.
5x - 10y = 15.
Is there anything I can multiply this green equation,
so that this article-2u becomes a member,
which will be canceled with -10y?
Basically i want to do this -2y
plus 10y. No?
Because if it is plus 10y, it will be canceled when
gather the left sides of these equations.
So what can I multiply this equation with?
If I multiply it by -5,
-5 by -2 here will be plus 10.
Let's do that.
Let's multiply this equation by -5.
Multiply the left side by -5 and
multiply the right side by -5.
And what do you get?
Do not forget that we in principle
we do not change the equation.
We do not change the information in the equation.
We do the same thing on both sides.
So the left side of the equation becomes
-5 by 3x is -15x.
And then -5 on -2y is plus 10y,
equal to 3 in -5, which is -15.
And now we are ready to make our elimination.
Add this to the left side of the yellow equation
and add - 15 to the right side of the yellow equation,
we add the same thing
to both sides of the equation.
Because this is equal to that.
So let's do that.
Let's do it.
5x - 15y, we have this negative sign there,
we do not want to lose it, it's -10x.
the authors are canceled.
-10y plus 10y is 0y.
This is the whole point of multiplying by -5.
Will be equal to ... -15 minus 15 is 0.
-10x is equal to 0.
We divide both sides to -10 and get
x is equal to 0.
And now we can substitute back into any of these equations,
to understand how much it should be.
Let's replace the above equation.
We get 5 at 0, minus 10y is equal to 15.
Or -10y is equal to 15.
Let me write it down.
-10y is equal to 15.
We divide the two sides to -10.
And we stay with y equals
-15/10, which is -3 / 2.
If we had to draw it, the point of intersection
with Ou would be a point (0; -3/2).
And you can check that it also satisfies this equation.
The initial equation here was
3x - 2u = 3.
3 at 0, which is 0, minus 2 at -3/2 is ... that's it
0, this is plus 3.
No?
These are canceled, this is positive.
Plus 3 is equal to 3.
So it really satisfies both equations.
Let's do one more of these tasks where we need to multiply
to convert the equations
and then we can eliminate one of the variables.
Let's do another task.
Say we have 5x + 7y = 15.
And we have 7 ... let's do it in another color
7x - 3y = 5.
Again, if you just collect or pull out
you will not remove the two left sides
none of the variables.
They do not have the same coefficient
or the negative of their coefficient.
So let's choose a variable to remove.
Let's say we want this time to remove the x.
And you can literally get it
or one variable or the other.
It does not matter.
You can decide to remove the scientists first.
But I choose to eliminate the xs first.
I have to convert one or both of these equations,
that these guys have the same odds,
or their coefficients have opposing signs,
so when I gather the left sides,
they will destroy each other.
There is nothing obvious here - I can multiply this by
some liver to make it equal to -5.
Or multiply this with some liver to make it equal to -7.
But even more fun thing I can do is try to put in both
their least common fold.
I can take on both 35.
And the way I can do it is by multiplying them one by one.
So I can multiply the above equation by 7.
Let's multiply the above equation by 7.
And I choose 7, so this will be 35.
And I can multiply the lower equation by -5.
I do this to make the coefficient -35.
Do not forget that my goal is to eliminate the x.
If this happens 35 and if I do this -35,
then I will be ready with everything.
I can gather the left and the right
sides of the equations.
In the above equation, when multiplying it by 7 ...
let's roll a little up ... we multiply it by 7,
becomes 35x + 49y is equal to ... to see, it is
70 + 35 is equal to 105.
No?
15 and 70, plus 35, is equal to 105.
This is where the above equation is transformed.
The lower equation is: -5 by 7x is -35x,
-5 by -3y is plus 15y.
Negative characters are canceled.
And then 5 ... this is not -5 ...
this is -5.
5 by -5 equals -25.
Now we can start with this upper equation and add the same thing
something to both sides where this one thing is -25,
which is also equal to this expression.
Let's collect her left
right sides.
Because we really add the same thing
to both sides of the equation.
So on the left side the hikes are canceled.
35x - 35x.
That was the whole point.
They are canceled and we receive 49y + 15y.
That's 64y.
64y is equal to 105 minus 25, equals 80.
We divide both sides at 64 and get y = 80/64.
And let's see if we divide the numerator and the denominator into 8 ...
you can actually do it with 16.
16 will be better.
But let's do it first with 8, just because
we know the table with 8.
This becomes 10/8 and then you can divide this to 2
and you get 5/4.
If you divide straight to 16,
you will stay straight with 5/4.
So y is equal to 5/4.
Let's find out how x is.
We can substitute for each of these equations
or in one of the initial equations.
Let's replace the second of the original equations,
where we had 7x - 3y = 5.
This was the initial version of the second equation, which
we later turned into that.
We get 7x minus 3 y - 5/4 - is equal to 5.
Or 7x - 15/4 = 5.
Let's add 15/4 ... Oh, I'm sorry I did not do it right.
This will be 7x minus 3 in 4 ... Oh, sorry, that was right.
What am I doing?
3 by 5/4 is 15/4.
Is equal to 5.
Let's add 15/4 to both sides. And so, plus 15/4, plus 15/4.
And what will we get?
The left hand is only 7x.
These guys are canceled.
And this will be equal to 5,
which is the same thing as 20/4.
20/4 plus 15/4.
Or get the following ... Let's roll a little down ...
7x is equal to 35/4.
We can multiply both sides by 1/7 or we can divide both
sides of 7, the same thing is.
Let's multiply both sides by 1/7.
The same thing as dividing the 7th.
These are canceled and left with x equal to ...
Here, if you divide 35 to 7, you get 5.
You divide 7 to 7, you get 1.
So x is equal to 5/4.
So the point of crossing this is -
and x, and y will be equal to 5/4.
If you look at this as a graph, the point is (5/4; 5/4).
And let's check if this satisfies the above equation.
If you take 5 5/4, plus 7 5/4,
what do you get?
It must be equal to 15.
So this is equal to 25/4 plus ... How much is that?
This is plus 35/4.
That is equal to 60/4, which is really equal to 15.
So this definitely satisfies the above equation.
You can check the lower equation for yourself,
but it should be because we actually used the lower equation,
to find that x is equal to 5/4.
.